still there's currently a distrust of
big Pharma in the public maybe this is
something I'd love to hear you comment
on
there's distrust of science when it's
tangled up with corporations and
government institutions like we've
talked about
but you have they have to be entangled
to achieve scale
oversight and to achieve the kind of
skill that pfizers they've been able to
accomplish
how can Pfizer regain the public Trust
how can you regain the public trust do
you think not regain but sort of take
steps to increase the public Trust
reputation is something that uh
you can lose in buckets but you can earn
back in drops
and once you lost it you are going to
take a lot of effort to bring it back
and the pharmaceutical industry lost it
it's clear but the reputation of the
industry in the last decade it was on
the lowest that we have seen ever and
for there are many reasons for that but
clearly there are reasons that are
related also with the behavior of the
industry
that needed to change and I'm hopeful
that uh
very few who disagree that the industry
is a very different industry right now
that being said
I truly believe
that if there is one lesson that stands
out from the main lessons that we
learned during covet
is the power of Science in the hands of
the private sector
I think it was the private sector
that came with Solutions with diagnostic
tests when we didn't have
Solutions with respirate when we didn't
have
Solutions with treatments Solutions with
vaccines
and I think that demonstrated very
clearly to the world the value
of thriving
Life Sciences sector private life
science and sector to society
that also affected very positively the
reputation
both of the sector and of Pfizer
I'm not going to make the mistake to
consider the given I'm not making to
make the mistake that because our
reputation is high that will remain so
we need to earn it every day every day
with everything we do with everything we
say with the way you behave and I hope
that will Rush this occasion and we'll
do that